so serezha may has been quite clear that
she does not want an Australian style
point system to control immigration post
brexit now as the if it's about is that
vote leave which her foreign secretary
Boris Johnson was one of the main
champions of they argued throughout the
referendum campaign for an Astra
Australian style point system Theresa
May says that she doesn't like it
because she thinks it doesn't actually
control immigration except it could lead
to higher numbers now I mean what you
see going on here is maze in some ways
defending her own record as ten sections
because they had a points-based system
for non EU migration and they didn't
even get nonny migration down to her
tens of thousands but you also see
something else which is one of the upon
the appeal of an australian arm point
system what they're able to go together
the two parts of the leave coalition one
one who can have one to control and
restrictions of immigration the other
one to different of global britain that
was relatively open on immigration the
australians are point system appealed to
both it's not clear though what teresa
may have in mind i think it is also
worth bearing in mind but just if you
talk to people in the home office they
say but they just don't have any
institutional capacity to to institute
open a visa program for all EU migrants
but it's the tension between controls on
immigration and Britain's trading
relationship with EU countries once it
does leave the European Union the the
theory is that you can't really have
strict controls on immigration whilst
remaining in the single market it
doesn't seem as a European need as a
particularly keen to start reforms to
what they've always said is a
fundamental cornerstone of the way the
bloc operates and to benefit from the
single market you have to sign up to
though to freedom of movement within the
European Union with with our the
European Union countries so this is
really difficult for Teresa mayor and as
we've also seen she has been snubbed by
world leaders at the g20 summit the
distance between her podium and that's a
Barack Obama's the way in which the
photograph was put together does look
very awkward but I think in the long run
this could benefit her because to have a
very awkward summit before the brexit
negotiations begin properly it's good
for her because she could if she does
manage together
a hard model of brexit which is what
those in her party are urging her for
along with the strong trading
relationship and she can say well look
where I started I had world leaders
absolutely furious with me European
leaders turning their backs on me Barack
Obama's will do back work and going to
the back of the queue in trade
negotiations but I managed to secure us
a deal anyway but that's the big if
because she still has to actually do
those negotiations and David Cameron's
for the EU referendum campaign claiming
that we've had a very difficult start
but he's never actually managed to
recover from that which was
Florida's campaign
well I think the today's press
conference was telling it was the first
time she has not looked in Oakland in
command as Prime Minister I mean there
was a meeting today we saw the limits of
how often she can keep saying brexit
means brexit because brexit means brexit
I mean there's something else so which
is this which is lots of the leaders of
this world the g20 summit are on the way
out Barack Obama's term animistic as
president of the United States I think
no one expects Francois Hollande to be
reelected as president of France and yet
there are lots publishers in Europe that
would like to dump Trump or Juncker as
president of the European Commission so
I think we shouldn't get too obsessed
about what these people have said
because lots of them on the way out the
door I mean the thing that probably will
cause some Maurice is what the Japanese
presenting this long list of demands for
brexit to the UK but what treasom a will
try and come grab hold of it was she
didn't have press conferences look she
is started talking to Australia South
Korea Singapore India Mexico about free
trade deals
once Britain leaves the EU I think that
that's what the government is going to
try and present there's a kind of good
news of breakfast look at the progress
we're making on these trade deals now
you obviously can't sign any of these
deals until Britain has left the EU it's
a better kind of question about how much
progress is really being made but I mean
that's how she'll try and do it I think
the crucial question comes which is what
is the attitude both of the leaders
elected in the French and German
elections in 2017 and the new president
of the United States
if TTIP dies which i think is the most
likely think now is the eu-us free-trade
deal then um there might be not much of
a coup for Britain to end up skipping
I think as James said she hasn't looked
as
she has previous succession she's also
had to answer some very difficult
questions or not answer them in her case
such as does she actually trust China
she wasn't able to say fully today that
that she did and that shows that the
difficulties that she's now having as
she starts work for real as Prime
Minister after the honeymoon period
where really everyone was away over the
summer and thought she was doing a
wonderful job partly because labour in
such a mess